has anyone approached you and said you
know what I just have to tell you this
and and I see you doing X and I think
you should be doing it why and I'm only
telling you this as a friend regarding
filmmaking right what you don't have to
tell me what it was about but what was
your response with that did you look at
it and say you know what they're right
did you realize I have another agenda
with that um it's only happened once it
was our film Rep Chris Pizzo on when we
were doing 10 till noon and he came to
guys doing this the wrong way about was
about festival submissions it was like
it was about premier status it was we
had submitted to smaller festivals and
bigger festivals and we hadn't heard
from the big vessels yet and said start
accepting small festivals not realizing
that if we played san francisco indie
South by Southwest wouldn't want us and
he was absolutely right and you know I
if someone comes to teach do that I mean
listen to them listen to them and if it
makes sense look at it research it there
right there right I mean you change what
you do that's how you learn you know
hopefully someone comes to you and tell
if you are doing something could be
doing things better doing something
wrong and they come to you and say maybe
do it this way then you learn thank God
they did thank God they came to you and
said that I haven't had anybody come up
to me and say you should do it this way
and it's totally not the way I would do
it unless they're not trying to sell me
something I have it like a film wrap up
to me and say should sign with me what
are you doing you know you could make
you millions of dollars I'm like no you
can't no show me your other films that
you've done that you know it it's but to
me I think it's pretty obvious in
someone's selling you something on when
someone actually is an expert in the
field know something you don't is
correcting you thank God for that course
correction you know I learned a lot for
that and it's made a difference moving
forward so yeah
you